[Music]
an easy job news whoo I don't know no
job that's easy you'll wait to hear
about this submitted by JK films
complete smooth oh thank you
a guy turned standing around four hours
into a business
laughter just standing around four hours
into a bit that's not easy that's
[ __ ] hard is hard standing around you
know what the easiest job is no job
matches tester oh I would love to be a
mattress no because ithat's are like
just take naps every day we got that
good D I got that good D yeah yeah yeah
part is a pretty easy job no hell no a
lot of work don't knock the poor no
you're not you're not having sex for
your pleasure activation and act not
getting into it cut all right so we need
to have another angle move whatever it's
like it's on their terms you know how to
find a dick show than you throw 40
different times the same way we'd get to
make the same noise in six hours
straight
all right I'll back off exactly you ever
seen any [ __ ] profession okay yeah
what other job would be easy maybe candy
tasting I get food tasting ice cream
taster I want to be ice cream taster
that's not that easy cuz then you're
gonna do it so much that you don't like
it no more
I know I can take on the daily basis I'm
sorry I explained that every day I love
it
my dream job for a long time ever since
I heard it a lot of Tanjung what was to
see Six Flags uh to be working for six
minor testing out all the roller
coasters around the whole world oh my
god but then you you're the first to die
yeah yeah I want to do that on the trail
session you know like math testing like
reviewing it like to see how good it is
all I could always use you have a
notepad
very very scary noise yeah boring okay
so the last turn was a little bit slow
not too sure did you have like a Korean
firm right oh yeah you do you have an
August Reaper a perm that's so cool make
sure you get a straight a before I carry
you you look like this wow you're like a
Hong Kong yeah ah damn shy all the time
you do that I'll do another and then you
just do one of these in your hairs
perfect again yes really soft hair yeah
my hair can't do that that's because her
hair is nice and thick my shits gonna
splat hope you guys dude I tell you once
you die it's just gonna grow a tree from
your head I know what the easiest job is
what watch shows oh yeah easy I can
watch shows on the like consistently for
a long time but I have to not have
anything else on the deck you know I
mean yeah because if it's not that I
just get an T lucky no you got something
else to finish yeah I'll have I'll have
a good show on but it can't be something
I'm paying attention to though I need
like white noise I can have a show on
everything interests me everything is up
wait what is this
storage wars I think he sold it for how
much
what if you're watching a movie like
glitter with Mariah Carey hmm you can't
get interested in that [ __ ] I don't know
something to buy just start looking at
sewed about that film okay no it's just
moving pictures I can't do it yeah I'm
not like that dude I get distracted by
it's just like a background even if it's
dumb I just get sucked in why do i watch
The Human Centipede the whole way
through it was supposed to be a
background noise no no that's that's
what happens to me I'm like I'm a for
laundry
turn out to be stupid I just watch the
whole movie now oh [ __ ]
no I need that back hey Tommy I'm like I
wish I should turn it off from two
periods for my own good I need to see
how this ends things
I have on our stuff that I've seen
already a million times st. Anna say man
I watch [ __ ] Fast Five for like the
50th time in estill recently Family Guy
Always Sunny in Philadelphia or the
office on because I've seen those all so
it's like I don't need to pay attention
to it mm-hmm
there's like a joke all here that makes
me laugh I didn't have to
well Bob's Burgers too is pretty good
yeah anyway this story is about a man
named Robert he's from New York and
Robert back in 2012 he lost his job
selling smartphones and so that year she
said that he spent most of his year
depressed solace wasn't the guy at the
mall denying slug-like hey what kind of
phone you have man [ __ ] you want to get
a Verizon [ __ ] man [ __ ] I already got a
[ __ ] phone dude no five you said that
like you know most of that time like he
was looking for work a lot and so she
said that when the iPhone 5 came out
that fall he had an idea and so he
posted on Craigslist saying that if
there was any way he'd be willing to
wait in line for that phone if anyone
wanted to pay him oh whoa how did you
even come up to that uh my friend so her
mom's would let me do whatever the [ __ ]
she wanted and then she some from a
friend of a friend of front of friends
she's like being hired for a [ __ ] if you
want to I'm like yeah I want one which
would you make uh I think you're just
depending on what it was I can't even
remember right now yeah it was it was
probably super negligible the photo like
fifty bucks or something probably less
than that uh yeah hey listen I see you
sent over six days on you Tim but of
course all yes then that's when I keep
sparked this that's dope I would hire
them but I would never do this yeah I
would never argue I think I'd rather do
something back to intense and at least
they'll stimulate me and the time flies
like I'd rather the [ __ ] break up a
sidewalk
concrete or some [ __ ] I said with a
jackhammer for eight hours and break my
back into standard and do nothing for
eight hours
that will kill me they don't do nothing
they they read books they bring out
their phones and we got a fan like they
bring out
there's like lawnchair so he created
this business called same old line dudes
and the way it works is for 25 he
charges $25 for the first hour and then
$10 for each additional 30 minutes and
that's how he's making money and so he
started hiring more people line sitters
he calls them so now he has 20 sitters
in his company but most of them are like
friends or like they'll hear about this
and I call my god can you hire me like
I'm down to do that that's genius
so he say Mike you've cost more than
50,000 hours in line or since he started
his business just crazy add stress-free
yeah and so he's saying like it's
awesome like all he does that he just
talks people in line or he'll take a
book or they'll just like sit there and
they just read whatever someone doesn't
come on time and then you get to the
front of the line and they go mix and
you're like aw [ __ ] I was holding this
place what it seems like is what they're
doing is they're standing in line to
obtain whatever like my product
yeah item like some shoes the New
Jordans coming out I get in line for me
oh I feel so the most popular thing that
people want to send in line for is like
for Hamilton tickets because they're so
coveted and so like he's saying like
sometimes like he'll stand in line but
then now they change the rules for
Hamilton because they're saying that
whether like if you buy tickets you have
to see that show so he say like I've
seen Hamilton like so many times like I
forgot how many times oh he's like I've
seen it so many times because he's
buying tickets for other customers he
also has to attend uni the show if he
buys tickets seems like that or like
concert tickets or a limited edition
you know shoes maker or even a seat at a
swanky bars what they're saying like
English for me to like be in contact
make sure that you're there by the time
he's in front of the line we are just
things like that I would love this for
restaurants oh because I get angry like
I'm so hungry and then I get there and
there's a [ __ ] lion I'm like ah like
a two-hour blonde and crap wait yeah
[ __ ] nobody got a blessed you with
[ __ ] three hours to wait like the 60
people that are ahead well it's not
three hours they probably wait like a
good 40 minutes to an hour
all the time I go to a place and they're
like I see our weight I'm like yelled as
a Mickey D's right around the corner oh
yeah yeah but that's true and then he's
also saying like there's a lot of
tourists that go to New York and you you
only have a limited time that you you
wanna do all these things we have to
stand in line and all the tourists in LA
every day I got time for that [ __ ] I got
so much LA to explore I would love to
hire these guys off standing line
affirmance I could get the world's best
ramen yeah I just want to walk in and go
and people go oh we go on and is a ramen
here and you chew but I'm smelling his
longest weight was 48 hours to get a
client on eight and iPhone 6s Wow one of
his sitters put in 52 hours to get a kid
a spot and exclusively New Jersey
preschool Wow yeah so then he's saying
like they'll even get hired to like get
certain things in New York City and then
drive out to like Connecticut or like
other other parts of that area and
deliver amazing like yeah we do all of
that so really looks at his business
that's awesome way to go you saw a void
and he sold it [ __ ] hate lines thank
you very much
whoever create a mental game online
never thank you no line etiquette is hey
I was saving this place but I'm
switching it with another person that's
cool because it's only one person but
you can't be like I'm saving this place
and 20 of your homies come
[ __ ] that [ __ ] through that that's a
fight Ice Cube special mm-hmm this is so
annoying grant you're at the grocery
store you just have like you see someone
that has a couple of things and they
bring the whole cart around after you
let him go in front of you I've never
had that happen to me happen to anyone
it's all it's always someone nice they
see me holding like three items and they
go you could go ahead I'm like you so
[ __ ] nice man I have that experience
I always do that for people is anything
they always did I do
what's the point like I'm gonna be here
for the next like three minutes checking
out just go ahead and he takes 30
seconds oh that's so nice I can never
say that when it's food hey guys I hope
you liked that episode of just kidding
news if you did please
press the like button to show us how
much you love it and for more videos
click right up here
[Music]